you have said chelsea that you have
specific rules for lovemaking when
you're with a guy
first of all not to use the term
lovemaking that's
that's very i'm old-fashioned yeah you
are you are old-fashioned
i don't i don't have rules for sex or
anything i mean i just you know it
should be
men shouldn't talk like you know
you shouldn't like make noises it's
embarrassing when men make noises
you know women should make noises women
listen women can get away you're lucky
that you're getting to have sex with us
in the first place so
we should we in the beginning i'm saying
before you get to know someone if you
haven't been with them for six months or
a year then
you know just keep it to a dull roar
like you know whatever you're thinking
like i don't like guys making a lot of
noise in bed it's embarrassing for us
it's embarrassing and it's hard to come
back from and faces when i mean you guys
all need to go home
every man should take care of himself in
front of a mirror and
look at the face that you make when you
climax and see look at what you do
because i don't think you guys know the
faces that you're making and you need to
look in the mirror look at that and see
is that something i want to take into
the bedroom
because usually and if yeah yeah yeah
exactly
this is this is that's not good
first of all you should shut your eyes
because my eyes are always open now
that's bad no i've been told that it's
really bad first when you open your eyes
as a woman and there's a guy on top and
you look and you're like why are you
looking at me so close
shut your eyes well what are your eyes
doing open
my eyes why are you judging i'm checking
to make sure that your eyes are closed
oh
when i open my eyes i'm checking to make
sure but men and you
just made a face that is very i could
tell that that is something you do in
bed and you can pretend it's not
but it's not that is my i'm telling you
that i do
like they do like there's this face that
meant go like like i had a boyfriend and
i didn't know it was like two years i
dated him and then i opened my eyes
this is his face okay no that's a
that's a galapagos sea turtle what are
you talking about that's why i said
hey buddy do you want to go take a look
at yourself because this
isn't making me want to finish what
we're doing
and you also need to take your socks off
everyone needs to take their socks off
do you have men don't take their socks
i've had that happen twice
and i didn't like it okay so take the
socks off
and don't have your head go back and
forth like eat yeah and don't if we
if we say something if a woman says
something in bed and we're a little
tipsy and we want to like scream out or
not scream out like say oh you know make
a suggestion
and if you don't hear us in the bedroom
and we don't know you that well
don't say what don't say
like we're not gonna just flip us over
and just act like you heard do something
okay
for god's sake i mean but i'm just
saying men don't understand how to be
cooler in bed and they need to be a
little bit cooler
yeah you've been married forever so i'm
sure your wife is already doing you a
bunch of favors
well by continuing to be married to me i
think she's making me a huge at least
there's no pressure dating you chelsea
no
i mean this is why yeah this is why i
have to go abroad
uh you say is this true that you won't
for a while you were dating older guys
and now you're saying no it's not
fun i'm an older man i'm done with older
men what's wrong with older men they're
just not that
i was getting too older like i was
eating like 20 years older than me and
that's just not fun because when older
men you know a man who an older man who
drinks is
like kind of it's kind of gross you know
it's fun i like to have a good time i
like to drink i like to have fun you
know do you ever go out with a guy who's
like in his 70s or 80s
[Laughter]
no but i've been dating a couple younger
guys and i like where that's headed more
you know i'm not yeah i'm not looking to
settle down so i think why not just
survey the land and see what's out there
yeah you know i'm a naked egalitarian i
like big guys little guys black ones
brown ones
that's good that's good that's very
you're very democratic about it you're
like i am
like the u.n yeah
it's like you know every time i come on
here we start talking about sex i don't
know if it's you or me or if it's our
probably not me
i'm just a creep that's all a creep that
lives behind that wall